[Musik]
kommen zu einem neuen blog es ist schon
abends wir beginnen doch erst abend wir
bekommen nachher besuchen sie dann aber
dann richtig coolen activity abend haben
sowieso platz schaffen wir schon nicht
mehr mogeln einfach ein bisschen kannst
du gleich
[Musik]
und auch schon wieder zurück also an
einem samstagabend nämlich wenn ich mit
einkaufen
da habe ich schon so einen körper
schnell erledigt jetzt nehme ich euch
immer mit beim essen vorbereiten
ich mache jetzt auf jeden fall die
kräfte aber mit der maschine ist schon
mal beim burghof du musst ein bisschen
10 ungefähr zehn minuten sondern was ich
hier vorbereitet habe ist mein hähnchen
aus dem ofen also hähnchenschenkel mit
ein bisschen paprika das rezept das gibt
es schon anleihen und das ist hier die
soße dafür eine stunde bevor die gäste
kommen schiebe ich dafür einfach in den
ofen
ich verliere ich übrigens alle rezepte
in die infobox und was ich auch schon
vorbereitet ist den salat den habe ich
hier geschnibbelt das dressing ist dass
honig senf dressing
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir sollen wir ganz gut der akku leer
wawrinka gegessen wird gezockt aber mas
leiter fühlen wer das hotel wie es darum
geht so gibt die mühe haben sagen gebt
dem höher praktisch lecker mittagessen
abendessen frühstück und sogar sehr gut
nein spaß ich das und sagen was ein
kuchen mich normal wir hatten doch in
der athene wenn dann wirklich
freundschaften haltet euch richtig gern
das pärchen das verloren hat zahlt für
flugsitze ganz ganz vorne das pro kopf 2
oder 15 euro ort wieder rückflug
nochmals zweimal vorne sind das machen
wieder 15 15 euro 2020 18 weiß warum der
flug der wirt sein
ich bin so müde mit einer runde gehören
und die andere verloren glaubt gar nicht
wissen wird ein satz wehrten leute
glaubt sich ich sage euch erstmal
gespielt werden 343 war ich sie so blass
aus weil es einfach so müde bin
aber der wetteinsatz war wir haben
nämlich sina und ich gegen hansa kogge
spielt also männer gegen frauen für
frauen geworden
wir dürfen uns nicht nur ein kinofilm
dem ist aufsuchen sondern haben sollen
müssen was peinliches machen und ich
werde das auf jeden fall film die müssen
mit einer tüte voller gekaufte
süßigkeiten vom supermarkt ins kino also
an die ticket werte vorbei dass wir
richtig witzig aber ich sage jetzt eine
gute nacht ich bin so blass und müde und
brauche erst mal schlafen dann sehen wir
uns morgen wieder gute nacht guten
morgen
aber wir sind jetzt gerade aufgewacht
und sind gerade auf einer halben stunde
haben sich direkt am pc direkt was
erledigen für das video und ich mache
jetzt frühstück dann schicke ich haben
sagt brötchen holen und ich zeige euch
mal wie ich so mein sonntags
schlemmerfrühstück machen
[Musik]
also dieses kabarett mit schafskäse und
petersilie gehen superschnell ich werde
euch das rezept einfach mal eine infobox
schreiben ja hallo
warum so dick angezogen haben sie lust
auf kaffee zum frühstück und twitter
sowie a mit der sauce gemeinschaft
granatapfel sieglose dies richtig gut
und ich muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen
gestern hat mir meine freundin
rentenversicherung mitgebracht weil
unser alle war der aus dem shop und das
hat mir gar nicht geschmeckt das war
richtig sauer
das war so sauer und unser ist halt halt
eine ganze teile zutaten ist also das
ist nur das nötigste drin einfach und es
schmeckt man auch schmeckt richtig gut
genauer will habe ich hier meine
mannschaft
gestern habe ich auch ganz viele
reformen habe ich auch meiner freundin
mit gegeben und die hier werden heute
ferner das wird echt lecker
die darf man sich nun nicht zu oft
kalorien aber die ordnung ist oder ob
wir eigentlich schon draußen los ist
kann hier mit dem backofen ganzen zettel
man sich auch sozial gern von dem was
sie können sich aussuchen ob er die
macht sondern die wachsen werde
[Applaus]
[Musik]
also wer mir gestern besuch bekommen von
sina und abo und die beiden haben uns
gefragt ob wir lust haben mit denen
zusammen
nein ich wollte spannungen steigen
lassen
na ist da wohl zu fliegen und ihr wisst
ja haben sie eigentlich lieben ist damit
also ist schon eine coole idee weil wir
uns auch überlegt haben dass wir uns um
silvester herum vielleicht so 45 tage
eine auszeit nehmen ist da wohl geht
einfach immer istanbul geht einfach
immer also wir checken jetzt mal die
ticketpreise
wir gucken jetzt mal was das alles
kostet natürlich viel zu überteuert ist
gerade zu zeiten silvester neujahr ist
immer alles ein bisschen teurer
mal gucken ob sich das so ganz
überteuert ist dann wohl eher nicht aber
wenn das budget dann kann man das doch
echt mal machen das jetzt hat der haben
sie gerade das rasante video geschnitten
und ich gucke mir jetzt mal anschauen ob
man irgendwas nicht auffällt und dann
ist es werde nie für mittwoch nahmen so
dann wollen wir mal
okay mir ist nur eine sache aufgefallen
und das ist ein tipp der noch hier rein
muss oder haben sie dann gleich machen
das video fasst ready es ist die bequem
gemacht
auch noch nicht du spielst jetzt einfach
auf der couch ich habe jetzt die sofa
die kein bisschen geändert eigentlich
müsste ich das jetzt voll schön und
ordentlich präsentieren da war hansa
stört ja so hier hat sich in der letzten
und vorletzten woche richtig was
angebahnt an kartons und langlebigen
keller müssen und sachen die
weggeschmissen werden müssen und das
seht ihr hier und heute habe ich endlich
zeit dieses chaos zu beseitigen
ran an die arbeit
also hier muss gleich gewischt werden
und alles weitere muss noch weggeräumt
werden aber ich habe mir gedacht wir
verschieben jetzt noch mal die couch und
dann sparen wir auch noch mal ein
bisschen platz weil wir könnten hier
echt noch ein stück nach links schieben
dann ist es auch nicht mehr so eng jetzt
haben wir hier viel mehr durchgangs
platz also wenn man hier durch liefert
das immer ein bisschen eng und so haben
wir echt viel mehr platz also gefällt
mir schon viel viel besser geht es sich
aber erstmal die kräfte schmecken
einfach 45 tage lang also hauptsache mit
frischhaltefolie bedecken und dann
könnte da echt 45 tage lang von essen
und das schmeckt einfach so lecker ich
glaube die meisten kennt ski küsste und
wer es nicht kennt unbedingt mein rezept
ausprobieren
meine um räumaktion fühle ich mich jetzt
schon viel wohler
ich weiß nicht wie braucht man dass alle
paar monate dass ich ein bisschen was um
rat auch wenn sie war damals als ich bei
meinen eltern noch gewohnt habe habe ich
eben mein zimmer umgestellt ist verrückt
weil ich sowieso immer das bett von
einwand zu anderen geschoben und den
schrank und auch meine arme eltern kugel
die sich leicht gerade ich würde sagen
hier passiert nicht mehr viel und wir
sehen uns morgen morgen des montag den
wir uns machen nochmal morgen wo sich
auch die gewinner vom letzten g aus vom
letzten block und dann verlor sich auch
schon neues paket also morgen also wir
sind jetzt im auto bzw
ich habe da kommt gerade das ist ein
mietwagen sie hat nämlich wie vor das
blog gestartet war ein termin in
heilbronn und ja da war und dass mit dem
jetzt ganz schnell frühstücken und dann
werden videos gedreht habe mich jetzt
mal umgezogen und wir drehen jetzt eine
oriol tort es schon eine
auch leute auf dem kanal aber leute dass
videos drei jahre alte so dass wir nicht
mithalten videos an gucke ich mir denke
oh mein gott aber ich glaube das hat
jeder aber ich glaube solche videos
zeigen wir noch die entwicklung des
kanals also eigentlich ist es ja
peinlich aber dann irgendwie auch nicht
naja egal auf jeden fall heute haben
jetzt noch schnell puderzucker mein
bruder zu kalle ist wenn das passiert
weil das habe ich immer auf vorrat und
verpackungen und dann kann es losgehen
und hab ich doch noch mal umgezogen
irgendwie war mir doch zu kalt in dem
dünnen pullover wir sind gerade
sozusagen mit einem dreh also haben sagt
die wichtigsten schritte aufgenommen und
ehrlich gesagt das mache die lichter aus
und meine seine nicht weg schmeckt weil
diesen echt heiß was ist heiß also die
die werden die werden halt warm und die
wärme verbreitet sich dann hier im raum
und deswegen streiche ich jetzt noch
ganz in ruhe die torte ein
so will ich möchte ja haben
ich selbst war mir ein video machen
einer veganen gemüse für die kleinen
schnitzel und das reden was du das mal
hintergrund ich verstehe gar nix gerade
in die kamera und du fühlst das nur mit
einer gewissen oft reden ja okay also
hinter den kulissen etwas abgebaut zu
machen sollte man gedanken wie kann man
das video kurzweilig gestalten welcher
schritt ist überflüssig
das bekommt ja alles gar nicht mit wie
das leben bei kaffeetrinkern die man
sehen dass nicht leben ist ja nicht
verboten menschen alles verbunden dass
er der frau kein maß du bist kein
diese typische frauen einfach ja
[Musik]
schneider wollte diesen englischen was
mir in london haben zusätzlich die torte
mit diesem oberteil angefangen hab also
muss jetzt auch wieder anziehen das
gemüse von den sitz fertig und die sich
irgendwie alles ums film heute omg ich
liebe grimms die konnten den
regelbetrieb ist sie darf nicht den
boden berühren und aber was stark wie
stark ich habe hunger wer morgen viertel
von 9 oder 20 49 gegessen gefrühstückt
und gesunde hören
ich bleibe bei meiner gesunden begann
gemüsepfanne einen riesenfehler gemacht
die haben mich hier mit dieser kalten
torte eingelassen und ich habe schon ein
stück gegessen wenn ich finde dass
nichts zu essen das ist lecker lecker
und thomas von leicht das glaubt man gar
nicht voll mächtig aus aber die ist
gleich ich meine es ernst ich könnte
noch eine aber sagt er
die war nicht oder ein ergebnis oder
einer geht noch einer geht noch
da haben sie es jetzt bei seinem freund
der wurde er eingeladen und ich habe
jetzt hier die gewinnerin vom letzten
gewinnspiel nicoletta liebe nicoletta
wenn du das jetzt liest dann tue bitte
eingefallen und schreibt mir eine kurze
e mail an info at s kitchen punkt.de
dann können wir alles weitere besprechen
und dann sende ich dir deinen gewinn zu
und heute gibt's natürlich wieder etwas
zu gewinnen also ich habe gesagt du bist
ja versprochen
dezember gibt blogs diese woche einen
und dann gibt es auch etwas zu gewinnen
heute gibt
ich habe so meine top ten favoriten die
einfach nicht fehlen dürfen und heute
verlose ich einen davon meine torten
säge natürlich nie die sondern eine
nagelneue die plätze nicht jemand wir
verlosen er aktuell noch die
küchenmaschine morgen nacht wird
ausgelost leute der frage echt hat ich
bin quasi kriegen wir deine benutzte
kriegsmaschine leute nein natürlich
nicht wissen dass so eine frage woher
die küchenmaschine gewinnen können
verleger ich euch in infobox da feiern
wir das 200.000 abonnenten zwischen aber
jetzt erstmal zum heutigen gewinn mit
meinem torten säge ist keine gewöhnliche
karten seht ihr alle kennt torten segen
die mit draht funktionieren was sind die
nachteile des draht das spornt mittels
zeit nicht mehr torten bild schief des
breis es sind einfach frustrierende
ergebnisse und wenn ihr euch um die mühe
macht und euren boden selber backen mit
ganz viel liebe in den backofen schieben
raus nimmt und ihn dann durch schneiden
möchte dann braucht ihr keinen draht
sondern dann braucht ihr eine säge und
wenn ich und wenn ich säge sage dann
meine ich auch säge schaut mal das ist
ein echtes sägeblatt das ist im
bankbereich echt eines der innovativsten
produkte die ich kenne und ich verlor
meine torten säge nicht nur das da kommt
natürlich auch zwei sachen dazu
zusätzlich gibt's die schnitten formen
die schulform ist insofern genial als
dass er da einfach alle torten alle
rezepte die für einen standard 26 cm
springform ausgelegt ist halbieren
könnte packt ihr sie in der städten form
die ist auch hitzebeständig und dann
habt ihr einfaches rezept für weniger
personen das ist wenn ihr einfach
weniger leute im haushalt sagt borisow
26 zentimeter toren die sind mir einfach
zu viel dann ist die schnitten vom
einfach perfekt für euch gehalten und
damit das schöne ist hat auch komplett
ist bekommt ihr eine original wiki
schütze in der farbe eurer wahl ich
hoffe ihr freut euch über das gummi
zusammen gestellte paket am run
teilnehmen zu können schreibt mir doch
einfach unten in die kommentare welches
rezept ihr euch ganz ganz ganz dringend
von mir wünschen welches soll ich
hochladen was ist dieses non-plus-ultra
wo ihr sagt kiki das musst du uns zeigen
und wenn es eins ist was ich schon
hochgeladen habe dann können sie mir das
auch gerne rein
und so weiß ich daneben möchte in den
lostopf hüpfen und im nächsten block
werde ich dann den gewinner oder die
gewinnerin verkünden jetzt wartet auf
mich noch volle ladung wäsche aus dem
trockner
ich freue mich aber bist du worauf ich
mich wirklich freue wenn ich welche
falte und damit fernsehen gucken kann
und dabei meine serie an schmeiße
aktuell noch modern family die neunte
staffel ansonsten brauche ich wieder
neuen input habt ihr irgendwie serien
empfehlungen dann schreibt es mir doch
bitte in die kommentare lassen es dann
doch noch ein bisschen austauschen von
gucken kann
zum abschalten einfach mal verarmung
ansonsten hoffe ich dass euch der block
gefallen hat war wirklich extrem alltags
blog diesmal alltag alltag alltag mal
gucken was uns im nächsten block
erwartet im nächsten block verrate ich
euch mal so ein bisschen was über eine
neue erfindung von uns aber dazu im
nächsten block mehr jetzt wenn ich den
blog ich freue mich jetzt schon eure
kommentare zu lesen ansonsten gibt's
morgen auf meinem canal di orio torte
generell wir haben so viele torten
abgedreht die erwarten euch alle
demnächst und dann würde ich mal sagen
macht's gut habt einen wunderschönen tag
und bis zum nächsten mal okay es gibt